hello guys my name is a channel and
welcome to episode three of the Genesis
series a series of videos in which we
look at one of my first-ever games in
fact my first love and dare game and we
just take a look at all the stuff that
was wrong with it all the stuff that was
right with it kind of just talk about it
and we'll see if we can fix any of the
issues or rewrite any of the
particularly bad codes so anyway last
time we talked about a whole bunch of
classes that existed in the actual game
it was mainly stuff like input and I
don't even think we talked I mean we
talked about the level about about the
menus and all that stuff but today I
promise we will talk about graphics and
rendering and then next episode if we if
we don't have time this episode which I
don't think we will because as you know
I like to talk next episode we will talk
about like the game logic and how all
that stuff works so I know that's like
quite a few videos because I think this
is episode 3 right up so for just like
the first full videos are gonna be like
just talking about the game and then I
guess to the remaining like however many
videos will just be kind of fixing it
and actually doing stuff I guess so I'm
not 100% sure what we what we're gonna
do with that
but um anyway looks like we'll just kind
of take this as it is I'm actually using
a different microphone as well this time
so let me know what you think about the
sound quality I mean it should sound
really good this is a really high-end
microphone that I use back in the back
in the music studio so anyway but I
thought I'd actually take it out and
record a video with it because I do love
the way it sounds ok so anyway now all
that aside let's begin so we will
probably take a look at like well I
guess we'll begin from the beginning
right I mean we we did we did cover kind
of Cherno color last time but the big
things that are in this graphics thing
ah let me just mute my phone the big
things that are in this graphics package
right which I'm assuming is going to
contain all the graphics is Maps green
sprite and sprite shade so we'll kind of
begin from map I guess I again remember
I have no idea how this works
oh I know what this is no we don't we
don't need to cover this at all this
actually wasn't in the original autumn
day game this was something that I
started adding afterwards
is something that I started adding on
afterwards when I when I decided to have
like a little mini map in the game in
fact I think you can actually bring that
up I think there's something why would
this be cold from well sure J I think no
reference to Norway really that's
totally a lie let's see yeah here it is
map Brenda commented out we uncomment
that
all right if we uncomment it yeah you
can see that we have this map here and
when I play or whatever let's find a
good level okay yeah you can see that we
have a mini map which shows females as
red dots and then I guess children's
brain dolls and you can see the true
female spawned here so it's good for
like both debugging but also like I
thought I might have it as a mechanic I
don't know just because it's obviously a
lot easier to play it's kind of like
cheating if you have the map because you
know exactly where everyone is more pink
than red but anyway you can see that as
I collide with this like another another
multiple spawn right you can see that
why that mini map anyway so I know a lot
of you probably gonna ask a little bit
about how that works it's really simple
and like the way I did it back down was
a bit weird but essentially we have the
width higher than the scale of the
mini-map so I just scale it up by two
just so that we wouldn't just said those
pixels would be even bigger and you
actually see them and then all I
literally did was I went through all of
the entities so this random method of
course was being called from the game
class Wow excuse me hang on what all
right I'm done so all the UM all the all
the all the rendering kind of happens
from the render method in the main class
in the game class so yes it was the last
thing that we rendered and then we just
called map at render we passed in both
the graphics context and the level we
cleared this Buffett image that we
created special especially for the map
we cleared it to black right with this
line and then we essentially just went
ahead and let's see what we did here
okay yeah so we essentially just went
through all the level entities we
divided their position by I don't know
why I wrote it that way but anyway we
divided that position by 16 to convert
it from like tiles into pixels I guess
open pixels and tiles and then we I
guess we assumed that the map was 128 by
128 or something like that because that
was also coincidentally the size of the
image and then of course we essentially
just okay so we even checked to see if
we could spawn a child and we changed
the color of the female going to that
and then of course if it was a player
then we set the color to white otherwise
for all other entities so in life if the
children and stuff we set the card it is
what you can see is quite high on the
green so that's why I see it as a green
kind of pixel and then we drew the image
okay I had a specific scale as well okay
and then that's pretty much it so it's
really easy like we essentially just
ensure pixels onto our bitmap based on
where entities were so that's the map
class nothing too fancy wasn't in the
original Adam dear submission so I don't
really want to cover that in any more
detail than I just did but I think that
should be enough detail anyway
alright the screen class is where all
the fun stuff happens because the screen
class the screen class actually contains
I believe most of the rendering code yep
so what we have in case you guys are not
not familiar with this rendering setup
which you should be because I'm assuming
a lot of you have watched the game
programming series but if you haven't
it's pretty simple basically essentially
what we do is we set up a buffered image
right which is just essentially like a
texture think of it as a texture so
that's kind of what it is with a certain
width and height obviously and with a
datatype right or a pixel kind of format
and then what we do here with this line
and it's a bit confusing because this
stuff all kind of happens - sorry
microphone this all kind of happens
statically in the sense that like you
can see it happens in the initialization
of the class it's not done in the
constructor probably should move that
down but anyway this line will happen
first right and then essentially we'll
get the pixels which is basically
obtaining the rasterization kind of data
buffer from the buffered image right and
then extracting its data which will
essentially well we'll get the data
buffer we'll convert it into a dot above
an int we know it's an int because we've
set the format to an int and then once
we have the data buffer int which is a
Java class we want to actually get the
integer array the primitive integer
array which is what we do by get data
and that's how we get the in pixels so
that is basically how that works now a
few things this is essentially our color
buffer right
familiar with kind of GPU rendering and
all that stuff this is what you would
call a color buffer right this is
basically the buffer that will
essentially be blurted onto the screen
when the buffers are swapped okay that
is the entire this pixels array which by
the way just so you know right this is a
this is an array right some Java arrays
are passed by reference which means that
what we're actually obtaining is a
reference to this array yeah this isn't
like some other array that we've created
or something because a lot of people I
remember like way from the game
programming days we're back from the
game growing days were like how is us
changing this pixels how does that
affect the image at all well all we're
doing here remember is we're not there
creating some other new integer array
we're just obtaining a reference to the
integer array which makes up this image
okay we're just taking that reference so
whenever we modified these pixels it's
actually modifying the pixels that make
up this image and so because of that we
can just do stuff like well we can just
write into our pixels array and then
draw the image and it will essentially
draw that pixels array okay so that's
how all of that works so because of that
and this is an interesting way it's
basically what's it's software rendering
it's never gonna be fast because what
we're doing is well apart from running
into an integer array and stuff we're
essentially kind of well we're losing
any kind of hardware acceleration
because we're dealing pixel per pixel
the only hardware acceleration that
would ever be possibly done is drawing
that final kind of image but again it's
Java and on what it's doing behind the
scenes it's probably really slow as well
so it's not it's not a great way to
render obviously but it is really nice
for pixel games because you do literally
get everything pixel per pixel you do
get full control you can theoretically
do anything with this like it's not
gonna be particularly fast but if you
want to render 3d stuff you could
totally do that
anything that you could do in like a
pixel shader or fragment shader if you
were using OpenGL DirectX you could do
with this obviously because you have the
entire array of pixels you can just you
know have a full loop that goes through
all of them and then write your shader
in there and there you have a fragment
shader or a pixel shader so anything is
possible with this right
it's just that it's gonna be really slow
so I of course nowadays wouldn't really
recommend doing that it is still I I
would honestly still write games like
this if the deal like if the goal was
like a retro kind of pixel game that was
like you know kind of Gameboy era esque
right something that was really low res
like you know I mean this isn't this is
kind of high res even but something that
was like I don't know what well like the
gameboy resolution was like 160 by nine
I get 160 about 120 or something I don't
know it's really lower right like
something low resolution that you can
then scale up at the end
this is totally perfect for and you will
get good performance out of it I mean
the game programming series I think runs
it like 2,000 FPS right and that scaled
up a little bit like three or four times
I think but anyway the point is this is
an interesting way of kind of rendering
I I was going to like way back I was
going to make a series just dedicated to
like covering this style of rendering
and what you can do with it because
again a lot of people don't understand
that you can actually do some really
cool lighting effects and you can do all
this cool stuff with it because well
you've got you've got you've got full
control over it which is really cool
so I don't know if you guys would be
interested in that and that's just
something that that I remember I wanted
to do like two years ago but never had
the time to so there's a lot of really
cool stuff we can do with this if anyway
that being said what we do is we create
the screen class which the screen class
is essentially just a class that is
dedicated to manipulating this pixels
array yeah that's really all it is we
can basically give we can pass the
screen around all of our kind of it's
like our rendering context it's
essentially our renderer right we pass
the screen class around all of our
classes that we want to be able to
render like you know mobs for example
and like you know level I guess well the
at the levels gonna have to render its
tiles and stuff like that
and they're all it has to do is say
stuff like hey screen I want you to
render a rectangle or I want to draw a
texture here or I want to you know draw
text or something that's the whole idea
I don't think we actually support text
but that is something that you can do
again so that's a screen so we created
it with a width and height you can see
what we do here is we have a public in
pixels so this is a
weird this is something I personally
don't like which I will probably make a
note of because we can fix this really
easily and it would probably boost the
performance a lot it's what I actually
do is I actually maintain my own pixels
around here which is again a bit weird
because you can see that what I'm doing
is I'm creating a completely new pixels
array which is the exact same size as
our screen okay and again this would
make sense if we had like multiple
screens or something but we don't so
what I'm doing is again width and height
of course is the width and height of our
game pre scaling because we're the scale
of it at the end when we actually like
bleed it onto our final kind of buffer
onto a screen buffer but um we had a
screen and we created new pixels array
for the Hat
and then we do all of our all of our
rendering to this pixels array and so
what happens at the end which is again
not right in this case is we have this
lovely line of code where we go through
every pixel and we copy it from we
essentially copy that screen pixels
array into our pixels array so that we
can draw it that's not gonna be too good
performance I mean like theoretically it
shouldn't be that slower but this is
like Java we're talking about so I think
that actually will be quite a little bit
of performance drain
I'm just curious real quick like if I
were to get rid of that so what are we
at 500 FPS yeah see just that whole
thing is like a hundred and fifty FPS
and obviously we can't like play like
this this screen is never gonna change
but you can see it's it's quite it's
quite a bit faster right if we're not
doing that copy which is a bit like it
shouldn't really be taking that much
time but it is so getting rid of that is
fairly simple we can just pass a
reference of our pixels right to the
screen class in fact I might do that
right now just like well we might do
this formally later but I'm just just
because it's such an easy and trivial
thing to do I just want to see how how
how much faster it'll be because this is
all we need to do
and now we can basically just we don't
need this anymore and it will still work
as it should right and so what is that
like I mean it's like 600 FPS which is
more than we had before so it's quite a
bit faster
because we're just avoiding that back
copy yeah so anyway that's something
that we can do I mean I've just done
that change now I thought I said this
would just be an exploratory kind of
episode but it's just such a simple
change so anyway so that that's how it
used to work right it used to create its
own pixels the way and then kind of
write stuff onto that and then we used
to copy it back onto our pixels array in
the game class so that we could draw it
and remember this pixels arrays actually
the pixels right from this image from
the buffered image whereas this is just
an integer array okay so anyway we have
our screen class we set up everything
here we have a clear method which
essentially will just set every pixel in
the array to zero so basically just do a
man set like to zero for all the pixels
the zero of course is black especially
in the 24-bit kind of algae becoming
format so essentially we just clear it's
going to black whenever we call clear
which I imagine will be at the beginning
of the frame yeah up here it is okay we
also have this screen top graphics j
which is interesting so we as soon as
week as soon as we create the well soon
as we obtain the draw graphics which is
essentially the graphics context we
immediately pass it into the screen
class so the screen class now has access
to this G thing which I'm assuming we
use for stuff yeah we use it for text
rendering okay because I didn't want to
write my own kind of text rendering
which is fair enough I mean it's gonna
be it that would that's not something
you want to do drink one there so we
have anyway moving on there we'll get it
we'll get to the text rendering later so
we have read a tile so this I'm assuming
gets cold from like all the kind of
level classes and essentially it will
just draw a tile water or oil is
essentially a texture so what we do here
first of all is we we have this X offset
and Y offset again something that is it
interesting like because it's not
typically something you would want to
store in a screen class I imagine
because it has nothing to do with the
renderer and everything to do with level
but essentially X offset and Y offset
would be the level offsets so we use the
set offset method which gets called from
the level render class right at the very
beginning and it basically just sets our
offset to our screen kind of scroll
right which is calculated from the
player I imagine yes so we have the X
scroll and Y scroll that are being
passed into leveled arenda and it
happens over here so let's just player X
- scream with / - so we've sent to the
player essentially okay that's all we're
doing so this X column Y scroll is
essentially going to be the offset of
the world based on the player's location
that's all it is and so we of course
need to do that so that when we move the
player and the camera moves essentially
it's a camera system right when the
camera moves the tiles essentially have
to get translated somewhere in both the
X and the y axis so that's what happens
here and that's why we have this offset
so if we request a tile to be rented at
0 0 because it's the you know at the top
left tile or something but the player
has moved the camera right then of
course we need to translate that tiles
location from 0 0 to wherever it
actually is based on the cameras
position so that's how that whole system
works it's pretty it's pretty simple
there's nothing really to complicated
about it it's just a simple offset but
it does a job and it's pretty simple I
just probably wouldn't do it in here
like I would probably if I was writing
this code to be better and if I cared
see a lot of this thing a lot a lot of
these things I have to I just feel I
have to mention this a lot of these
things are not done because I was
necessarily a bad programmer back then I
mean some of them certainly were done
because I was a bad programmer back then
but a lot of these were just done
because like it was by far the simplest
way to do it and there's no real
downside like doing it this way there is
no real downside I mean technically it
doesn't really make too much sense and
it will probably limit how versatile
this class is but we're not running a
game engine here right we're writing a
game for a 48 hour game for during
competition right and this is I think
this game was about 20 hours of work
from me and that's including stuff like
music so like actual programming is
probably like 15 hours or so
so it's really not that like it's not
it's it's hard to be like it's hard to
criticize my code too harshly in some
cases of course in other cases that
criticism is is needed but in some ups
in some cases such as this it's like
well yes it's not that correct but it
kind of is in the context of this game
and this competition so I don't know
again I'm going to try and criticize as
code as if it was something that a
studio produced after like a year
development cycle or something because
or maybe not that much but you know I'm
gonna obviously try and treat this as if
it wasn't created in a 48-hour game
programming competition because you know
I could use that excuse everywhere like
oh yeah but it was easier to do it this
way or I had an idea but that I changed
my mind so this is the code that's left
over from that you know what I mean like
there's so many things that could happen
so I'm gonna pretend that this wasn't I
guess full of that but anyway in that
case if this wasn't flood I'm dead and
yes I definitely wouldn't have this here
I would probably have this offset in a
level class and when you go to render it
that's when you actually pass in the
positions already offset into this as
parameters right so you would do this
calculation outside of the rendering
then you would do this back in the level
class okay cool anyway and you'll
probably even have a camera class and
you could even have something like a
camera apply translation or something
like that and you'd pass in two numbers
and you would get two numbers back that
have the transform applied to it so in
fact that would probably be even better
right delegating all that work to a
camera class this this does not contain
a camera for as far as we're concerned
tonight okay and I wouldn't think it
would either because again a camera is a
construct that you make when you're
trying to do things properly nor when
you're trying to make a game in a short
amount of time okay anyway okay he would
do rendering so we have the for each
loops here or the for loops that go
through both all the X&Y tiles of course
square which is why we have the size
repeated twice here see one thing that I
do like that I did do back then is I
always wrote my fault I always
right out my for-loops in kind of the X
pygmy in a loop and the Y being the
outer loop okay and that's really
important because if you switch these
two around like that right that's
actually going to result in completely
different performance right it's gonna
be a lot worse and the reason is that if
you decide to read an array in memory
and I'm gonna dwell too much on this but
if you decided to read an array in
memory you know kind of why first then
you're actually kind of skipping you
know I mean if if tile does write two
sides like I don't know I think this is
like sixteen or something I think it
would be probably loaded in yeah but
there be sixteen by sixteen right
essentially if you were writing it down
instead of a cross then you would be
skipping you'd be reading like multiples
of 16 as indices right so you're
skipping all of those pixels and you're
kind of jumping across a whole bunch of
pixels at once right you're not reading
in a row which is terrible because
essentially you're breaking you're gonna
result in CPU cache misses all the time
right because what happens again I'm not
really gonna give you a lesson about
this right now but just to summarize
when you request you know data from
memory from your city like with your CPU
it prefetches a lot more than you
request right if you request like an
integer it's not gonna give you an
integer it's gonna return you like a
whole bunch of data that is starting at
that integer address and going forward
so what happens is if you decide to read
data that is directly adjacent to or
next to your original memory address
that you're reading which would be like
one of these pixels for example if you
read the next pixel then that's already
gonna be on on your CPU cache and
because of that that memory read it's
gonna be a thousand times faster right
but more like a hundred times faster but
anyway it's gonna be a lot faster right
and so if you decide to not do that if
you decide to read your array like all
over the place like you would be if this
four loop was inversed
right then you're basically throwing
away all the stuff that's on your CPU
cache I mean this is very small though
it is sixteen by sixteen so it's not a
cute it was like thousand 24 by thousand
24 then you would definitely see a huge
decrease in performance but even even
something like that though
really good habit to get him to just
write your follow-ups properly which is
like this I mean I've never written them
any other way because the way that I
first saw them written was like this
which is correct but I do see some
people write the Forex part first and
then the for Y which is just completely
wrong
right so yeah so anyway so to stay on
your CPU cache you want to be reading
stuff like this right you want to try
and read memory that is closer together
rather than further apart as your
ultimate goal okay cool
so anyway one other thing I want to
quickly mention regarding memory and
performance is stuff like that is a lot
of people always ask me why I don't use
two-dimensional arrays because
two-dimensional arrays in some cases to
some people make more sense because of
course a level is 2d this is a 2-d game
so why are the pixels not 2d the reason
I don't use two-dimensional arrays is
because again they have a kind of the
same problem in terms of how the memory
is laid out a two-dimensional array is
essentially an array of arrays right so
you have an array of pointers which
point to other arrays and those arrays
are going to be in various locations in
memory so when you decide to read
certain pixels from certain array it's
almost all is you're essentially adding
another indirection all right you have
to hit a memory read to obtain a pointer
to the address of a of an array that is
somewhere else in memory like it's just
it's absolutely terrible and your
performance is just gonna tank really
hard so I don't use two-dimensional
arrays because a they're terrible like
they're pretty bad for the performance
especially like for rendering right
because we're hitting them so often
we're hitting these things like hundreds
of times per frame right it's it's crazy
probably even thousands but also not
just because the performance also I just
find it neater to just have this I mean
you know having your x-coordinate plus
your y-coordinate at times your width is
just I mean I'm just used to it and I
think this looks fine as opposed to
something like this which would probably
have typically in an inverse order as
well so you'd have like you know that
essentially right I honestly I honestly
prefer this it just makes more sense to
me okay so that's a little
explanation of two-dimensional arrays
and why I'm not using them particularly
but yes the primary reason would be
performance but also because I don't
like them I mean I do use them sometimes
just not for like performance critical
code like rendering you wouldn't find
many two-dimensional arrays being used
in rendering I think anywhere ok so
anyway getting along with this I'm gonna
drink some water because I've been
talking for a while so this is why I
mean these videos have now gone forever
it's been like 25 minutes and before you
know what I want to say I've got stuff
to do with my life and leave again so we
don't want to I don't want that happen
so let's just let's just get on with
this so yeah so we go through tiles
which is square we get the XT that what
is the St y plus YP okay right so this
is the position of the tile okay I see
this is the position of the tile on the
screen right so--but we basically get
the position of the tile in the level we
translate it to the position of the tile
on the screen right so getting screens
in this XP and YP after this offset is
in screen space now and then what we do
is we essentially create a new variable
called Y T which is the actual pixel
that we're dealing with so it's of
course the offset of where it is on the
screen plus the plus the value of this Y
in our for loop right so it's the actual
pixel coordinate so while this stuff is
per tile this stuff is now per pixel XT
and YT we do some we do a little if
check here to see whether or not wow
that is that is some interesting code
okay so we check to see whether or not
essentially our pixel is in the bounds
of our screen right so that we we
basically clip it to the screen but the
thing that I'm there are two things here
that are weird there are two things here
that will win right the first one is
this XT is less than - tireless writer
sighs right so less than negative 16
first of all negative 16 or anything
between negative 16 and negative
inclusive is not a valid place for pixel
to be so it will result in the rain
decks at about a session and crash right
but furthermore not to mention that
we've also got this directly under it
which is sets it to zero anyway right so
that is a little bit interesting I mean
I can see what it's doing I can kind of
see what it's doing since we do have a
break here so what it is doing is it
saying that if it's like you know
anything below negative sixteen will
just quit out completely but if it is
between negative 16 and negative one
right then we will clip it well we
weren't clip it we'll set it to zero
right which is again extremely weird and
we do that for Y as well so and the
other thing the second thing that's
weird is we have this break right which
will just you know abort rendering that
entire tile whereas what we probably
should do is continue break will
definitely give you high performance
because again we just abandon that tile
which again is why we have this negative
tile size I imagine if we had this as
zero in fact it will test us out right
now but if we had this as zero we'll be
losing a bunch of tiles because again
we're breaking so let's see what this
looks like hmm actually seems to work
surprisingly ah now here we go
whoops see these black areas there we go
I'm surprised that it's not happening up
here but anyway all these black areas
are result of that whole thing so what
we really should have done is just hit
continue and if we do continue you can
see we don't get those black things
because we only skip rendering certain
pixels rather than the entire tile if
one pixel is out of bounds and then we
also don't need the need for this
anymore so that would be kind of fixing
that up that will potentially result in
reduced performance though because we
are rendering pixels that we worked
before but I don't think it will since
we were just clipping them to zero
anyway so that's an updated way to do
that that is a lot better I'm not sure
what I was thinking exactly I think I
was just oh and you know what that will
do as well that will fix that weird bug
that we had
remember how in the first episode I said
that like this was being clipped or
something yeah you can see that tree you
can see we have this line here right if
I change this to be that then I'll cable
those are the trees anyways that's not
gonna we need to change that in the tree
code but essentially that will be why
right it'll be because of that because
we're setting it to zero if it's out of
balance essentially all right so back to
this so then we get the color all right
and we obtained that by looking up our
sprite at X plus y times fragile size
now x and y of course art is this for
loop that isn't it that is in between 0
and 15 ryan inclusive because that will
be you know this this sprite to size
will be 16 right so we're going through
that so basically x and y are always
going to be a coordinate of our sprite
in terms of pixels and then we have of
course multiplying it by the sprite
width which is the sprite size because
it's square said multiplying it by 16 so
that we can get the appropriate
coordinate in the array and that gives
us the sprites color so what we have now
is an if check that basically checks to
see if the color is pink or purple and
if it's either pink or purple sorry if
it's not pink or purple so if it's
either pink or purple then we don't
render the pit the pixel essentially we
don't render the pixel however if we
also do it another check here to see if
the tile is not an instance of torch
tile so if it's if the tile that we're
rendering is not a torched and we apply
our color change to it a brightness
change that's our level brightness so
this is this light is us applying a
lighting to the actual pixel based on
the levels kind of brightness so this is
this is not lighting so to speak like as
in this isn't the torch light or
whatever it's not what you see from the
torch light this is just the the
like though the natural light yes that's
a good way of saying and I think natural
light in terms of this is just the light
at the level right without lights
applied so because of course we have a
day/night cycle the level will get dark
it will get darker because the the
natural light will kind of decrease and
then it will increase again so that's
what this is doing it's changing the
brightness which of course is just
essentially reducing the brightness of
each color channel right and that's what
we're setting color to so we're passing
in the original color and we're getting
back the color with the brightness
applied to it okay and I apologize for
any noise outside there seems to be like
people just mowing lawns and stuff but
anyway so this is what we do here and we
don't do that if it's a torch tile
because I assume we want the torch child
to remain the same right and like
essentially we just want the torch tile
to remain the same brightness regardless
of the regarding regardless of natural
light because it's always gonna be
emitting light is basically the is
basically the concern that okay cool and
then we have our final kind of line here
which is the most important line of the
function probably which actually sets
our pixels which is what we see on the
screen eventually to to that color okay
now of course this can be I do I do say
that this is what we see in the screen
eventually but of course this can be
overwritten before we do render it
because we can render stuff on top of
things so that may not actually be on
the final kind of thing but it will be
this hair man sorry I gotta get my hair
on the control you'll see me do that
quite often throughout the video anyway
so that's us finally rendering that and
that is how we render tiles
okay it's pretty simple there is an
almost identical render tile method here
that actually should not exist but does
anyway I mean I guess it's a little bit
different the only thing different about
this will apart with the fact that it
takes in a sprite rather than a tiled
course is that we don't do the check for
the torch tile right so even if we
decide to render at wash
it will apply brightness to it now there
are a few things that are obviously
wrong about this whole thing right and I
mentioned the first thing was this also
stuff like having hey if this isn't a
torch tile right in our renderer is very
bad but it's also something again that
is like yep it's love and air and this
is obviously a specific renderer for
this specific game so it's not something
that it's not something that is
particularly evil in this case 30 oh my
goodness man these videos take up so
much time I don't understand
has it really been like over half now
what have I been doing
I need to watch some of you I think I
need to watch some of these back and see
what I actually do during the time
because like we're halfway through like
essentially the first like graphics
class anyway you guys want to in-depth
the videos from me here you go this is
this is pretty deep but anyway this
could obviously be like it does have
that one small change which I doubt does
anything so this whole thing could just
be rewritten as a render tile XP YP I
just sort of just read that up that
night I meant to do it the other way
around so you could kind of rewrite this
whole thing as reddit I'll what what
excuse me
entitled UPS Brian right you just do
that now that of course in this case
would render tortures incorrectly
because we don't have that magical check
to see if the tile isn't an instance of
a torch but you guys kind of get the
idea I probably could have done
something like that and we can't do that
if check in here unfortunately because
we don't know the tile at that point
we'd only have as bright but yeah so
stuff like that could be rewritten to be
a bit better you can see this still has
that dodgy piece of code which I will
fix on the fly okay random mob wow this
is some exciting code so we have a few
parameters here we've got an integer
called flip and a boolean called hurt
which we don't actually use I imagine
that I like you can't really hurt see
this this is what I love about looking
through old kind of source code you get
to see stuff that like stuff that was
kind of in development but didn't make
it to the final game like there is
nothing in this game currently that will
hurt you right but why is there a hurt
variable right it kinda gets the plot
thickens right it kind of gets exciting
so I believe I did I did it initially
start to add enemies but I didn't have
time so essentially what that hurt thing
was was a I guess a boolean whether or
not the that mob was taking damage and
if so I probably would have like made
the color tinted red or something right
in fact that's probably where that
colleton tenet could have been used as
well or maybe I just would have made
them on flash white or flash red or
something right so I'm I'm guessing I
don't remember at all what that was for
but anyway um so we have this we do the
offset of course the camera offset
now here we don't even bother with using
variables like sprite out sighs that's
that's tough that stuff is lame right
we're pro so we just used 16 so that's
fun of course that is the sprite size we
then get the pixel and then we get this
Y s which is called Y which is just
equal to Y for down okay I know pursuing
that ties in with the flipping
yes so it flips right how did we flip
sprites so flipping first of all is
something that we use to essentially
like literally flip a sprite right so we
essentially scale it like- 100% by
either X or Y or rather ether vertically
or horizontally or both right working
both as well I imagine most of it's
probably horizontal there because if the
mob is moving left versus right we don't
want to have two different sprites we
can just mirror them so that's what the
flipping does first of all so obviously
flipping that there are kind of three
there are four states of flipping 0 1 2
& 3 and this is me all obviously just
taking this from the source code we have
zero which does that which is no flip we
have one which is just an X flip we have
two which is just a Y flip and we have
three which is both an X and a y flip
which is why we have this so that being
said all we have to do is essentially
just reverse the order in which we kind
of read pixels right so you can see that
we read pixels using xs and ys but what
we do here is instead of like kind of
reading pixels 0 1 2 3 4 5 etc we do we
instead do 15 14 13 12 10 11 right we
read it in reverse order that's all we
do right that's all the flip does it's
literally a flip in the order that we
read pixels and of course by reading
pixels this way right reading pixels
right to left but obviously you know
setting them in the color buffer as left
to right we end up with a flipped image
so that's our flipping works then we
have this comedy code once again which I
will be fixing you can see here we have
negative 15 and negative 16 you know
okayed that again is interesting why we
have 15 here and 16 here and not 16 in
both or 15 of both weird but anyway
that's gone and just check it was still
XT yep okay then we have of course the
color which we take from the mob mob
sprites pixels we check to see if the
color is not pink or purple and then
what we do here is
okay so if uh yes this is great this is
the good code so if the mob that we're
drawing is a female and the female can
spawn a child and the current pixels
color is this which is kind of a red
color yeah
very red kind of color then we set the
color to green okay so this is what this
is that tag that you see on females I
really need to disable the other levels
where's the female find me a female all
right so this tag that you see on
females this citiz green kind of thing
right that is of course that shows
whether or not they they can spawn
children or not right so basically what
we do is if they can spawn children then
we set this tag to be green okay which
is this color
if they can't spawn children then we
don't we don't run this if statements so
we don't change the color at all so that
would mean that in the original sprite
sheet that color was actually red
originally so let me just confirm that
so this is a resources a surprise of
course of what I want yeah I love the
fact that my windows 10 is broken and
doesn't like have photo of your or
something but yeah so you can say that
originally it's red okay and that red of
course you can see is BC 2 a 2 3 which
is BC 2 a 2 3 so if the color is equal
to that then we change the color of only
those pixels you can see that this like
color doesn't exist anywhere else on the
female right only here so this this
solid color if if we're about to render
a pixel that is of that color and then
we will change the color to be
essentially this color
which will be this kind of grain and you
can say that you confirm that by just
passing this in there yeah there's that
great color okay so that's how that
works it's pretty simple it's just it's
just a it's just a really simple case of
changing a color on the fly if it is a
certain college to begin with okay so if
the color is less than zero so the color
would be less than zero Wow the color
should never be less than zero
ah no will be here wait this is very odd
it's weird okay this whole thing is a
bit weird because the color should never
be less than zero because we are
rendering a 24-bit yes we're rendering a
24-bit color
essentially it's just RGB right and if
we haven't heard it a bit integers in
Java are assigned and we have a 32-bit
signed integer which means that the
color can only ever be negative if we
are using more than 31 bits so to speak
right so the color is higher than
2-billion for example it kind of will
spill over into into negativity but so
essentially if we have something that
begins with FF then yes that will be
negative if you convert it into a sign
integer because that requires unsigned
right because it's that big so that
being said this now will be kind of a
negative number
probably however we don't we our final
render doesn't need that extra channel
so I'm not sure why we didn't just do
something like that I mean fair enough
reading that original color from the mob
it would probably be ready and like Java
would read like because I think the way
that we read this stuff inside sprite
probably spreadsheet yeah we're ready
just as a buffered image so this will
really read these the image format of
the actual image that was exported which
apparently was 32-bit rgba which is why
we have this extra channel that's what
we need this when we check and not just
that right because it does
that alpha channel that we need to also
check for otherwise the numbers of
course not equal and yeah so we could
adjust on that but we didn't which said
to that and then we saved the color of
less than zero and if it is that's
actually incredibly weird I'm not sure
what that code exactly trying to do hmm
okay whatever anyway so Mott and then we
apply lighting to the mob I guess so
this is gonna be this is important code
because we're gonna have to fix this
eventually but we have we change the
brightness of the color based on the
level of course and this by the way will
return a thirty to this to change
brightness returns a 24-bit color anyway
you can see it has no alpha Channel so
that's even weirder like we seem to have
a discrepancy here between having an
alpha Channel and not having an alpha
Channel which is not good I probably
didn't know what that was back then so I
mean I know I would have because I wrote
stuff like this right so I probably just
didn't think of it and then we have this
so basically if the mob light distance
is less than zero okay right so if the
mobs okay so if the mob systems with
light is less than zero then we just
apply the regular level brightness
otherwise we we basically multiply the
brightness of yeah so based on how far
away the mob is from the light we will
basically will basically make them
brighter if they're closer to the light
that's what that will do but I guess
that the light distance will get set to
negative one or something if the mob is
a certain distance away from a torch or
something like that
what are we at 45 minutes it's time to
wrap this up we're gonna finish this
class and then we're gonna be done for
today so okay cool and then we have the
pixels of course which tests this up ah
this local isn't zero
I I don't get it at all color will as
far as I can see color will always be
less than zero
once I'm very wrong let's remove this
and see what happens because I honestly
don't quite know whether or not like I
don't quite see that happening so I
guess we'll see it when I guess we'll
see it if yeah so we should see that
applied to both I just don't so it it
that's also also saying that we'll all
will only change the brightness if the
color is less than zero that is very
weird
if anyone can remember what on earth I
was smoking when I wrote this code this
should always be true as far as I can
tell because of whatever whatever
whatever we read
yeah this has to always be true there is
no way this isn't always true now that I
think about it because the most
significant bit is always going to be
one since our well it's set to F and
it's always maybe set to F because even
though this is a 32-bit color the Alpha
is always gonna be full which means that
the 32nd bit is always gonna be 1 which
means that it's the number is always
going to be negative because it's
getting Carson to a signed integer yes
that distance you can see with the light
that makes a darker sometimes but it
also doesn't work half the time or is
dodgy that is because there yeah I don't
know this code shouldn't be here I don't
think that matters maybe there was
something maybe that's a result of me
trying to do something in the past and
then changing my mind or something but
it doesn't make any sense right now
because as long as there are 32-bit
colors which they're always always will
be in this case I mean it's hard coded
to always have to have a 32-bit color
otherwise game just wouldn't look
correct it'll always yeah it'll always
be like that I mean it seems to work I
don't know that's I need to take a look
at that ok render light again we do the
I don't know what this does at all so it
looks like we taking a tile and RGB and
intensity so we do our normal code with
this crazy stuff we do access which is
just a call to X okay I wouldn't even
need that and right this could just be X
I guess and then we have color which is
again from the tiles fryer where is this
cold from render light from light tile
ok cool interesting we should look at
light tile look at lighting ok since
we're already past the time limit we're
going to look at the light rendering
stuff next time exclusively the light
rendering stuff including light tile
class and all of this stuff but to wrap
this up we have our set offset function
which is really
of course just sets up our offset says
our offset fields to the parameters and
then we have read a text so render text
will basically render us text with a
certain color again I don't know why I
did this because I believe there is a
constructor at least now that whereas
maybe there wasn't back in the day but
there is a constructor that just takes
in a color see I could just on that okay
other stuff that is bad is me creating a
new font every time don't want to do
that at all because that's going to be
slow I'm imagining that it's gonna have
to like create a new texture and then
fill it with like glyphs which is not
good unless Java has some internal kind
of caching stuff I don't know if we
would be able to see that as in we would
be able to say that but I don't know if
Java would be would have actually done
that because it is Java and you know
they're not really that good okay so
yeah this is just I'll sure okay that's
struct out so it doesn't look like they
have any kind of cache
I'm not gonna spend too much time
looking at this right now I'm just
saying if there's anything here that
surely they have to have a cache that
come on there's no way that they
wouldn't have a cache that's the
stupidest thing ever
I'm just gonna assume they have a cache
because fonts should always have caches
create font
yeah they've got a helper fund that's
from a font file okay whatever I'm not
gonna look at this now but I'm assuming
they have a cache because that would be
madness if they didn't okay anyways but
still creating this phone is bad news
don't do that again I'm not sure if oh
no what if the reason what if the reason
that my meet my font rendering on the
menu was so slow was because it used
this code and this did didn't have a
cage no oh that's nice
well that's fun I hope you guys learned
something because next time we're gonna
add a cache and see what happens this is
on my to-do okay I'm going to leave to
do so we're gonna catch that and that's
that's my biggest to do really I mean
we've already done out to do which was
I'll still leave the two dues there I
think
big hard and well I mean the thing that
we did do this time was facing up was
fixing up our pixels here right and not
doing that but apart from that yeah next
time or the sub part probably not next
time but we will definitely catch this
and see what happens because I'm
predicting it's just gonna be a lot
faster that it almost definitely will be
a lot faster okay cool anyway and then
of course the way that we render a font
here is in this case we extract a bunch
of colors which we didn't need to
because it's constructor takes in color
anyway it might be a CA might want a
32-bit color oh no this is RGB yeah but
it might want like a 32-bit color and
not a 69 24-bit color but anyway
whatever I'm sure I could figure it out
figure out the fact that the Alpha
channel 0 or something but anyway and
then we have a font we create it's
always gonna be verdana there and then
we set the color of the graphics context
right so we do what we do text rendering
on-the-fly meaning that there is no kind
of submission there's no cue we just
render it like as soon as you call
running text it will draw it onto the
buffer 107 so G set color to whatever
we just created from these RGB values
that we specified using this integer
color which is here using the font that
we just create every time here and then
we draw the string at the given X&Y okay
and this of course will be used
primarily by the menu I imagine but
probably by everything really I mean we
render stuff I click to focus we render
stuff like the population the population
display right we render at the timer and
then we render of course all of the
menus which is a lot of stuff to render
okay so ease that quite heavily the
thing that the thing that's important to
remember there though is that it should
like text will always be written over
top of other stuff right because in our
main rendering order we draw our image
first right and then we do stuff like
yeah so we're n right we render our
level stuff then we draw our image and
then after that we would be rendering
all of our other stuff like our menus
and stuff yeah menu don't render you can
see happens here population all right it
happens here because of course this
image takes up the entire I'm sorry my
friend this image takes up the entire
the entire screen buffer and it's not
transparent or anything at all and it's
the entire screen so we have to render
the test in front of it otherwise the
worst attacks at all but yeah okay cool
anyway and then we don't this stuff
laughter as well and then the time up
okay so that is it that is the screen
class next time I'm gonna talk about
lighting and then after that we're gonna
take a little water come talk about game
logic and stuff but anyway because to
draw this video if you did please hit
like button and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
you
Oh